i have a connection with with technology
i like it i like to learn more about it
and
here it's not just about uh
my passion and when i go to a client or
to a factory uh first the first thing i
do is explain about the technology and
what they can achieve
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl an in media
partnership with ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm being joined by anisse abu
al-hassan business development manager
of siraj technologies
anis is the business development manager
at siraj technologies a startup
specializing in connectivity allowing
seamless adoption of industry 4.0
technologies and he's graduated from
sapir college with a bachelor's degree
in technology marketing with health
technology specialization and currently
studying for a master's degree in health
systems management at ben gurion
university also anisse is also a
researcher of the economic evaluation of
pharmaceutical interventions with
published articles
anis abu elassan welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you all the way from ben
gurion university is that where you are
right now uh i'm in the gaviano high
tech park it's near bengal university uh
beautiful neighbors
i i love it so and if you are
business development at siraj
technologies working on connectivity and
and industry 4.0
and you were a disappear before
a better when and i'm excited to really
understand your personal journey better
you're also understanding about industry
4.0 and siraj technologies in general so
why don't we start with your journey a
little bit i'd love to get to know you
better and and how how you how how you
are experiencing the tech ecosystem from
your end yeah
definitely well i grew up in
in a bedouin city called roth and uh
at first i studied six years in a
bedroom school
but then my family thought about
that i will get a better education if i
continued my study in kibbutz it was
called kibbutz chowal
so in my
last seven years of studying in high
school i was in a jewish school
uh studying there
and after i filled my school i uh i went
to germany to visit my brother but also
to try and see if i
if if i can study medicine there
and after uh thinking about the
situation and if i wanted to continue uh
or to start studying medicine and i
decided that
it wasn't for me i have
a twin brother and sister
they both studied medicine and they are
triplets
no
i have a brother and sister they are
twins they are older than in okay okay
so they both started at the same time
studying medicine my brother in germany
my sister in turkey
the typical
let's say
educational journey of
the bedroom or the arab community when
you say
let's study something or let's do uh
learn a job it's usually if you are
either a lawyer or a
doctor and
their traditional
three or four jobs that
they are the top and everyone's trying
to learn them
so i decided to to study here in
in israel at the end i want to study
technology marketing at sapir college
it's near the road
and while i studying there i decided to
take a specialization in
in health technologies which is
something that
interests me until this day i'm
currently studying master's degree in
ben gurion
systems management
and doing research in health technology
adoption and pharmaceutical economic
evaluations
and this is a sort of
habit a hobby or
academic career let's say it
in the future
and right now technology it's always
interested me everything is always
changing and that's why i'm working
right now in a startup
and uh i mean
tell me a little bit about siraj
technologies um and about both what it's
about but also the name
and how that's special to the mission of
what you're working on definitely
definitely well
it means a source of light and at the
beginning uh our founders uh dr gilroy
aron and
sheikh they are
dr
is a highly known entrepreneur in israel
and uh sheikh is a bedouin businessman
they met each other and wanted to do
something for the bedroom community but
not just giving money or giving some
some talk about how to promote the
bedroom people so they decided to do
something they created strategy ngo
which is a
non
which is an organization that helps bad
ones to
know more about
startups high tech and all the education
that comes with it starting from high
schools
and then helping students
and they wanted to create a role model a
role model not a person but a company
that will
will teach them and show them that
it's not just a dream but he also can
accomplish it
and
they found its raj and
along the way it was in 2016 and today
we started the
five engineers and today we are 25
employees
and most of them are bedouins
so study in ben gurion or in some shimon
and
and we are developing technology that
will allow
a seamless adoption of industry 4.0
technologies
and to make that
in a simple world when we speak about
industry 4.0 it's about leveraging data
and to collect data and try to
understand it and create value from
something that exists using analytical
tools and
other different technologies
and
we found a challenge that in
in a factory or in a manufacturing or
any iot device speaks mostly differently
from each other
we can say it about even the protocol of
the communication or the data itself
and when you need to analyze data you
need to have it structured in a specific
way so we can analyze it so we decided
to develop
a solution that will use a artificial
intelligence and will unify the data
that
afterward can be analyzed
monitored and all the other stuff
and right now we are basically bridging
between the
the factories
the operations and the other
startups
that
develop technologies to
analyze this data
and
this way we can also say that we are
shedding light on
the new technologies and allowing
all those manufacturers to leverage this
uh this revolution it's called the
industry 4.
but it actually is the fourth industrial
revolution
right now i i take me back a little bit
about your journey and i want to
understand a little bit better your
personal interest
in industry 4.0 working in in the high
tech ecosystem
you you you grew up in a different
environment than the traditional
high-tech employees of israel right this
is something that we that is often being
discussed you know on the on the news
about this the the gap of of upbringing
and the entrance to the tech ecosystem
which is
right now still
you know much more common amongst those
that are liv that are growing up closer
to the center of israel
what was it like for you and why what
what led you to the conviction that you
want to be a part of the tech ecosystem
so as i said i always wanted to learn
more and to understand and technology
it's from
the
beginning i i'm not all an old person
i'm 27 years old but i remember when we
used to call for the internet
at least in israel or when i lived i
remember the days
when we used to wait three days to
download the video game
wow yeah which today is it doesn't exist
or maybe
in either it was the internet was faster
but in the bedroom areas it was slower
so in terms of technology i myself
as i said studied in a
in a kibbutz or in a jewish school which
is well experimental school
so when i was in the 10th grade they
introduced us with e-learning
i'm speaking about 2012 and it was
something new to bring a computer to
your school and to start study and
all of those stuff that
that comes with the internet and with
technology and it was always interested
but in
in my times
i still
had no idea about computer science or
what
or how how do you compute what does it
mean to understand all those languages
and so when i went to study technology
marketing and that's when the first i i
understand what is the startup or what
is the high-tech community
and what is the meaning of high
technology
and most of people
might not know the definition of
technology which is applied science it's
something that you can apply it so when
we say high tech there are sometimes
manufacturing
a glass can be high-tech even though
it's uh just a glass it doesn't have to
be a computer the technology behind it
can be high-tech
right that makes a lot of sense and so
when now as you go back home and
i i don't know
is it do you have a large community
around you that is also in the tech
ecosystem back from where you are and
honestly no
honestly no most of
the people that i know from my community
from my family are usually
workers
and most of them some of them
study bachelor's degree but most of them
are uh
finish high school and then start a job
and continue
and continue working with life
an interesting thing i i read recently
an article about uh
the high tech
and the bedouin community in the high
tech from calculus and it said that
there are 350 000 people in the high
tech in israel
but only 50 are from the billion
community
50 55 000 yeah
exactly i'm not sure how accurate it is
but i can say if it's true then at 20
high tickets are from our company but uh
that's the well
that means that i'm speaking i'm
speaking to two percent of the better
and ecosystem in in israel in terms of
tech and and that's and that's
definitely not okay you know from your
perspective and your
personal lens
what what are some what are some
tangible things that that should take
place in order to to bridge the gap
because obviously it's a horrible
horrible gap first of all it's about
community to be honest because until
this day in order to
to find a job in the high tech sector
it's usually a friend brings a friend
and if you don't have a friend in the
high tech then
it will be very hard for you to to get
accepted or to to find the job
and
the second thing is what we are trying
to do is to encourage
students in the high school
to
to study more mathematics to be better
in english
so they can go to the university and be
able to earn an engineering degree or in
a college
and after that we have training programs
that allow them to experience how uh
how we are working in a high-tech
company and a startup what it means to
work with teams
and how to create projects and there are
different a lot of things that we are
trying to do
first of all is to spread awareness uh
there is nothing wrong with studying
medicine
but you also can
study computer sciences
and also you can study something like me
the business or marketing and
and work in a startup or in a high-tech
company
and everything starts from awareness as
a marketing person like i said awareness
is the first step
and once once we spread awareness maybe
from our
podcast right now people will say uh
only 50 bedrooms maybe there are there
are probably more
who are waiting to for for the chance
and maybe they will try and see is
seek those persons
and we will be happy to help
encourage more people to to start
their journey
and as you go back home and and and you
are sharing your personal experiences
and you're obviously working on things
that are that are perhaps different
what is the reception like do people
understand what what do you do do they
is it supportive do you feel like it's
taking it apart from your previous
community
and bridging
new communities what impact does this
have on your personal life
uh i think i i first of all try to
encourage encourage
the people surrounding me to to study
and to learn and
today even with the with the covet we
know this more
there is you can you can learn anywhere
you just need to
to have awareness
and
the materials to study and after that
it's it's about it's about you
and
i encourage them that they actually can
there are other jobs it's hard to find
job yes exactly at the beginning but
this is a journey that it's worth
taking it
and
as i said
we can't start with saying why they are
there are uh
a few people in the high tech sector or
how many people are ready to be a part
of the high tech sector
when we have a lot of people who have
studied and graduated from computer
science and other
technology related uh
technology related degrees then there
will be
more people in the high tech
and
right that makes a lot of sense now
going back to to your work with industry
4.0 and connectivity which brings me
back a lot to you know the story that
you mentioned growing up having to dial
the internet waiting for three days for
something to download obviously today
you're working on resolving and not just
resolving it but actually you know
taking it a few steps into the future
and the fourth industrial revolution
tell me about your current work in your
day-to-day in business development
within suraj technologies
so today basically what we are doing is
we are helping to bridge between two
parts uh for example we work with the
siemens
in a project that
they provide the platform and we allow
them to easily connect their customers
their the machines in the factories to
their platform
we also worked with the netafem in the
and icl in the agriculture sector which
is a
a well-known or an international company
for irrigation systems
and we also worked with
a lot of
environmental companies in israel and
they all have
the same challenge
they have sensors machines and they need
to monitor them using the cloud
and we help them to to to take this step
and the first step is also to digitize
all those
processes when we speak about
digital print
most of the factories they don't have it
we can speak about industry 4.0 and
to create value but first of all we need
the data we need something to connect
and everything today can be solved with
the
the internet of things
any process and
we are doing great right now with all
the companies we are doing working with
is in israel uh
alongside with the you know with their
innovation authority trying to help
the factories
in the south uh to to start and
use the technology more to
uh to manufacture more and to grow
and that's uh
that's in in a few words as i can say
now when you when you look
personally by the things that you're
passionate about
is this the subject that you're really
excited about personally is it
do you think that it stems from from
your upbringing from where from where
you came from
or is this or is it something that that
you're just observing that a lot of
places in the world also need
i
personally i can uh i have a connection
with with technology i like it i like to
learn more about it
and
here it's not just about uh
my passion and when i go to a client or
to a factory uh first the first thing i
do is
explain them about the technology and
what they can achieve it's not just
solving a specific pro specific problem
when we speak about industry 4.0 there
are a lot of verticals and there is
value in adopting these technologies but
most of the factories right now
especially in israel
they have
they don't really have uh
i don't want to say new machines but
sophisticated machines automation
existed for 20 30 40 years even more
and sure
you you will find in a factory a machine
that is 40 years old that is doing uh
its job greatly
but
right now what we will do is to
understand
how the machine work how the process
works right and then you start
connecting
erp systems with the with the
manufacturing trying to understand
customer trends and try to define the
and optimize all this those little
little processes that
humans mostly can't
analyze it
it's uh right
we can speak about predictive
maintenance which is
a machine that
starts to learn how we have worked for
for months and sometimes years and try
to predict what would be the outcome and
for
most of the companies this can
reduce the cost but also
bring them more knowledge about what
they are actually doing
it makes a lot of sense and any so i
really want to thank you for coming and
being both open about your own you know
your own perspective from the veteran
community but also your experience with
working on connectivity and industry 4.0
and i really appreciate it i want we
have just a couple minutes left and i
want to take you back and to your to
your childhood and you know just growing
up what really fascinated you as a kid
to be honest
economics that's what's fascinating i
always used to calculate everything and
a simple story would be
me and my brother would always
have this game and if we won a lottery
what would be what would you buy and he
would say i would buy cars houses and a
lot of things and i would listen to him
until the end and tell them you know
you you don't have money for guests so
what are you gonna do with the cars now
so i'm always
and
i like to understand that's why
why i studied marketing
i want to know to understand all the uh
the variables within
within a business or within a process
and try to understand
what can make me feel and what can make
me succeed and without even starting
beginning
the journey
and
curiosity basically in one word
i love it and what what inspires you
today you know as you go day by day
what inspires me is is to learn more i
i probably mentioned a little bit but
as as of my master's degree i'm also
doing research and
i an economic research it's well the
same
the same thing
so i always try to understand to learn
more and to evaluate and to to take
decisions and
not just for myself but also to to help
others to take their decisions so i'm
also uh i can call myself a researcher
and i
and that's another part that inspires me
to always learn more and there are
always new things
and so learning
is the best thing for me
amazing what are three words you would
use to describe yourself
uh passionate
curious
and
disciplined
denise thank you so much this is great
thank you for the great work you're
doing the great impact that you're
having and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you michael and thank
you for this opportunity have a great
day thank you bye